another day another tenth blog coffee on
a Tuesday and vlog 50 in vlog 48 I
talked about reality how growing up it
seemed to me that much of our social
arrangements our convention less rules
than communal guidelines only as strong
as the community makes them and since
the community is nothing but people its
rules its reality is as malleable as
fluid as we are in vlog 49 I without
saying so challenge that premise
somewhat by asking whether or not you
should give money to panhandlers now it
would be silly to think that by asking
such a question I was trying to get at
the incidental convention of my given
community at my given time even if that
type of answer is the most forthcoming I
was trying to uncover a deeper rule a
rule applicable to all circumstances and
all times I was trying to suss out the
older and wiser sister of convention its
partner in the social universe the moral
rule today I'd like to complete this
trilogy of videos and complete this line
of thinking about morality as best I can
morality is about oh it's about what we
ought to do when formulating a moral
rule we're not saying what we should do
in order for this or that to happen we
have to be confident that what we say is
applicable to all people as a general
rule for example let's say your friend
tells you that they just got a new
haircut they love it but they want to
know what you think well you may think
it looks bad but you say that it doesn't
because you don't want to hurt their
field
now the moral rule isn't don't tell
Jerry his bowl cut looks like [ __ ]
because he's got a thin skin clearly
that applies only to Jerry the moral
rule might be worded don't make people
feel sad if you can help it maybe you
think it's right to tell Jerry that his
haircut is unflattering you value the
truth even if it hurts another
legitimate moral rule always be honest
you can see that morality is about right
with a capital R and wrong with a
capital W and of course people can
disagree on that like Jerry's two types
of friends but that's a pretty innocuous
example here's another from Jonathan
hates the righteous mind this
whether the people in this story have
done something morally wrong so a family
has a dog named spot that they love
they've lived with him for many years
one day spot is tragically killed by a
car in front of the family's house the
family having heard that dog meat is
delicious cut up spots body cook it and
eat him for dinner nobody sees them do
this so what do you think as hate
explains what you're probably feeling is
disgust you want to say that this family
has done something wrong but then you
remember it's their dog who was already
dead so they didn't hurt it and nobody
saw them so nobody was offended maybe in
the end you decide that what the family
did was disgusting something that you
would never dream of doing but morally
wrong well you have to say no if that's
your answer if that's the way you feel
you're most likely from the West and
you're most likely a Lib your morality
boils down more or less to what the
utilitarian genius John Stuart Mill
wrote in his essay on liberty what most
Western governments are based on the
only purpose for which power can be
rightly exercised over any member of a
civilized community against his will is
to prevent harm to others in other words
maybe they're not people you'd want to
be friends with but it's their dog
they're eating it nobody was hurt so
leave them alone now if on the other
hand you hear this story and you still
say yes this is morally wrong then you
are working off another axis of morality
and to understand it we have to look
closer at what hate calls moral
foundations theory the six axes of
morality mixed and matched in different
people's around the world first we have
care harm what we've essentially already
covered and what makes up most of the
Western liberal morality making sure
that nobody is hurt unless they're
trying to hurt others and that everyone
is properly cared for second you have
fairness cheating something that will
also be familiar to us we believe that
people should reap a proportional share
of what they sow and we despise those
who try to get more for less were third
loyalty betrayal what makes us feel
pride for our groups whether they be
sports teams or political parties or
Nations and what makes us feel rage
against those who are traitors to them
fourth authority subversion which
highlights the feeling that we need
leaders and that we fall into some
man-made or natural hierarchies like a
or corporation navigating this moral
terrain means respecting your superiors
while gaining the respect from those
below you so that you can move up and
down the social ladder without
triggering number 5 liberty oppression
we have a sense of when vulnerable
groups are being exploited or when our
liberties are being infringed upon say
by a tyrant this can be interpreted
differently based on what your political
leaning is and finally number 6 sanctity
degradation what may cause us to feel
that yes eating your own dog is morally
wrong there are higher and lower ways of
life this foundation holds like a
spectrum stretching from lowly
degenerates to pure Souls the Western
liberal morality as I said leans heavily
on the care harm foundation with a
little bit of fairness cheating and
liberty oppression thrown in liberals
don't care so much about the other three
in fact they may rail against them as in
more but ours is not the only morality
in the world many cultures in fact most
cultures in fact some in our own country
put a lot of their stock in sanctity
degradation for example especially
religious culture the Bible and other
sacred texts are filled with rules on
how you're supposed to act to align
yourself with God for what reason should
the Bible teach abstinence or the Torah
forbid pork if not that chastity is
considered godly and pork is considered
unclean and impure these are just a
couple of the modern manifestations of
sanctity degradation and like Authority
subversion and loyalty betrayal
they are felt more strongly in cultures
where the community is the central unit
not the individual this is why
patriarchal societies exist in which
there are roles for women that would
make feminists gasp but in which those
women don't speak out because they see
the family as more important than
themselves all of these are real
moralities and each foundation is the
product of millions of years of
evolution they were naturally selected
to overcome certain adaptive challenges
like caring for one's children or
forming cohesive coalition's or avoiding
contaminants of course the modern
triggers for these foundations can be
very different from the original ones a
hundred thousand years ago staying pure
meant staying clean to avoid infection
passing on animal meat that was rotten
or poisonous today it finds expression
in virtue and vice as they say
cleanliness
next to godliness the essential point is
that morality a product of evolution
functions on more axes than simply the
Golden Rule
that's a descriptive fact about humans
and understanding all six foundations
will help you not to immediately brush
off as stupid or evil those who think
differently than you it's not to say to
be clear that all morality z' and all
moral foundations are equally good but
deciding what combination is best for
society is the work of another field
called normative ethics it's work I'm
afraid that I ought to leave up to you
[Music]
hey everybody thank you so much for
sticking with me for 50 vlogs like I
can't believe we've done that many I
think the nerdwriter has transformed a
lot since the begin you know this is not
a vlog about back toads or look just
learning stuff it's a lot about building
world that's what the experiment of the
nerd writer is and I don't mean for you
to take my world view and that's what
these videos are it's to see how you can
build one for yourself if you want to
watch parts 1 & 2 of the morality
trilogy you can find them here also
don't forget to follow me on tumblr and
Twitter links in the description I hope
you stay with me for another 50 blogs
I'm excited to talk about more
interesting more complex or subtle stuff
thanks